i think it's really great to like
support females particularly um
female entrepreneurs cool future great
awesome danielle danielle
morrissey and her daughter stephanie
jessica whatever you should really talk
to her you know no
it's just a job time my mom is so sorry
for your loss
no funny business with maya thank you
i think everyone that's bi is
experimenting you have zero gaydar
excuse me kid i lived through new york
in the 80s my gaydar is strong
you can't just like show up to like the
after party for a shiva
and like reap the benefits of the she
lost so much weight
yeah you think she has an eating
disorder
again feminism isn't exactly what i call
a career it's not my career it's a lens
max worked for your father years ago
really
just try to behave yourself today i'm
not gonna blow him in the bathroom
why do you keep looking over there hi
i'm ken beckett i don't think she's
pretty
malibu barbie's not pretty i mean she's
just like
basic you are such a good kid
[Music]
so you just study and
don't eat and go out with your beautiful
friends
is that it
is that your life yeah yes that's my
life
wow lucky you
mom who died